a new stream of lava has begun flowing
from the volcano erupting on the spanish
island of la palma the lava is
threatening to engulf more homes in
addition to the hundreds that have
already been damaged or destroyed but
while the volcano is posing a serious
danger to lives and property it's also
attracting visitors to the island eager
to see the spectacle of a volcano in
action
thousands have fled from its destructive
force but others are attracted the
erupting cumbre vieja is now another
tourist attraction on this holiday isle
some have traveled to snap a selfie with
an erupting
volcano a once in a lifetime opportunity
to see something like this and we just
thought it was uh you know worth making
the journey so we got the ferry across
and it's very sad seeing the lava going
down here because it looks like it might
it's destroying quite a lot more houses
but still it's good to see you know the
natural the beauty of this
it's incredible there's a lot of noise
it's the power and the beauty of the
volcano
but many island residents are wishing
for an end to the instability
thousands have been forced to evacuate
some have lost everything
the land i had is all gone
the inheritance i had there
it's all gone
lava continues to devour properties
the moving molten mass has consumed more
than a thousand buildings in the three
weeks since eruptions began
setting fire to everything in its path
recent nights have seen fresh flows from
the fiery mountain as the unstable cone
collapses and new fissures appear
sending rivers of magma in different
directions
cumbro vieja shows no sign of settling
down